[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEEVANA HEGDE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jeevana Hegde, a customer
engineer at Google Cloud.
And welcome back to the
"Technical Guide for Startups,"
where we are helping startups
for technical enablement
to start, build and grow
their businesses successfully
and sustainably on Google Cloud.
In our previous video, we
introduced you to the series,
and now we're on to the
second episode, which
is all about getting
started on Google Cloud.
In this video, we are
going to be covering
how to create a Google Cloud
account so you get started
on the Google
Cloud platform, get
a brief overview of
the resource hierarchy,
understand why an
organization is important
and how to create one,
how to create a folder,
how to create a project,
and do an entire run-through
of the Google
Cloud console so we
get the fundamentals in place.
And finally, we will be going
over identity and access
management for building
your security fundamentals,
and wrap up with some
actionable next steps.
So without any further
ado, let's get on
to exploring the Google
Cloud platform together.
Before jumping onto
the demonstration,
there's something you
need to keep in mind.
Once you create your
account, you actually
need to activate it
in order to use it.
And for this, you'll be required
to put in your payment details.
By default, you're provided
with $300 of credit.
And this is more than
sufficient in case
you're just planning to
experiment or practice
for a certification.
Once those credits
are over, you will
have to manually upgrade
to a payment tier
to continue working.
So don't worry, as you
are not auto charged
once your trial expires.
But in any case, it's
always good to know
that you have to deallocate,
delete, and stop the resources
that you do not require.
Now let's go with the
absolute fundamental step,
which is creating your
Google Cloud account.
To start off, I've opened
an incognito window,
which makes it
convenient in case
you're working with
different accounts.
And then, open up the
console.cloud.google.com.
Now, we either
create a new account
or we can simply sign
into an existing one.
If you have it, just put in
your credentials and log in.
Now, here, let's go over
how to create a new one.
Click on Create
account and choose
for myself or my business, but
know that the steps are pretty
much the same in any case.
Fill in the details, like
the name, email address,
create a new one if you have to.
And also set a strong password.
Once you're done, click on Next.
You're then asked to
fill in the phone number,
and a verification
code is sent to it.
So put in this
code when prompted.
Once you have all
of that verified,
your Google Cloud platform
opens up, but with the pop up.
All you have left to do
is select your country now
and agree to the
terms of service.
Click on the check box and
click on agree and continue.
Congratulations, now you have
yourself your Google Cloud
account.
But, like I already mentioned,
you now need to activate it.
So let's go ahead and do that.
This is a three-step method.
Select your country and
tell us what describes
your organization the best.
I'd probably go ahead
here and say startup,
and click on Continue.
And when you do, you are asked
to verify the phone number
that you want to be contacted
in case of any support
issues, et cetera.
And then, go to the final step.
And finally, all you have to do
is confirm your account type,
fill in your business name,
fill in your payment method
and your card
details, et cetera,
and understand all the
information in detail.
And all you have to do is
click on Start my free trial.
Now that we've begun our
journey by creating an account,
let's go over understanding
what the resource
hierarchy on Google Cloud is.
A resource hierarchy
helps us understand
how your resources are
going to be organized, which
is extremely crucial when your
organization is scaling out,
and is a great foundation
to understanding inheritance
of access control and
organization policies
for your resources.
To the bottom most
of the hierarchy,
we have all our resources,
which are essentially
all the products and services,
like your Compute Engine
instances, machine
learning APIs, databases,
and everything else.
This is where your
application really stands.
Resources can only be
parented by projects.
And this becomes the first
coping mechanism in your Google
Cloud resource hierarchy.
You need to have at
least one project
to get started with
building your resources.
It is a best practice that you
segregate your projects based
on your environment, such
as development, test,
and production.
This way, the flow is kept
clean, easy to manage,
debugged, and scaled.
Right above projects
we have folders.
These folders can contain other
projects, as well as folders.
This provides an additional
grouping mechanism
to help keep your resources
and accesses restricted
maybe department-wise,
team-wise, and so on.
Maybe you wouldn't want to
research team's resources
to be accessed by the
other departments.
So you can keep them
isolated, yet under one roof.
And that one roof
is an organization.
This is the umbrella
for your entire company
and acts as the root node.
It is a prerequisite for you to
have an organization in order
to use folders.
Now that we have a
broad understanding
of the entire
resource hierarchy,
let's try and understand
an organization
in a little more detail
and why it's so important.
Organizations provide central
visibility and control
over every resource that
belongs to that organization.
The IAM access control policies
applied to an organization
apply throughout the hierarchy
to all the resources.
It is not required or mandatory
to have an organization,
but some features
of resource manager
will not be usable without one.
If you are a Google
Workspace or Cloud Identity
user, when you create
a Google Cloud project,
an organization is
automatically provisioned.
Now without any further ado,
let's jump onto the demo.
I'm doing so by creating
a Cloud Identity account.
The link to this is in
the description box below.
Now click on Next.
Put in your business name and
select the number of employees
present in your company.
I'm picking 100 to 299 for
the purpose of this demo.
And then click on Next.
Select your business location
and business phone number.
Moving on, provide your
current email address.
I'm just going to go ahead
and type in a mock email
address here.
And then add in your
business' domain name address.
Once you've added
this, you're asked
to verify it and
confirm, just to be sure.
Once you confirm
it, the next step
is to put in the account
administrator's full name.
You can change who you give this
rule to even once it's created.
So know that you
don't necessarily
have to be the
permanent one in charge,
even though you're
creating it right now.
Anyway, we are quickly
moving on to the next step.
It's for you to pick a username
and a very strong password
for your Cloud Identity account.
And then click on Next.
The last few steps
would be for you
to choose whether
or not you want
to educate your users regarding
Workspace apps, new features,
et cetera.
I'm just going to say no,
thank you for now and move on.
The final step is simply
for you to confirm
that you're not a
robot, and then click on
agree and Create Account.
Congratulations!
Now you have yourself a
Cloud Identity account,
which also means you have an
organization for you to get
started with.
Now that we have
an organization,
we can create a folder.
So let's go ahead and try that.
Click here and you can see
which organization is open.
Now click on these three dots
and select Manage resources.
This takes you to where you can
see a hierarchy very clearly.
But remember, you need
the right access controls
in the first place to be
able to view all of this,
and we'll come to
that in just a bit.
Now let's create our folder.
I'm going to quickly
give it a name.
Let me call
demo-startups-jeevana.
So maybe all my
demos are going to be
present under this folder.
And now I can
browse where I want
to be creating this folder.
Let me directly
say this is going
to be under the organization,
and then click on Create.
Now we just wait a
couple of seconds,
and when we have the refresh
notification pop up here,
we simply refresh the screen.
And that's it.
We have our folder here.
Now quickly from where
we left off, let's create
a project, because
otherwise, you can't really
provision any resources.
Let's try to create this
and see what happens.
Click on Create Project
to create a new one.
As you can see, it's
already given me
a name and a project ID.
The project ID needs to
be a globally unique one.
And it's not necessary for the
project name and ID to match,
but it's a best
practice to do so,
as it's just easier to
fetch in the future.
And the project ID cannot be
changed once it's created.
Let me just try and type
in a unique name here,
maybe technical guide demos.
So if I'll remove
the demos from this,
you can see it adds a new
variables automatically
for the project ID to
make it globally unique.
But let's leave it at
technical guide demos
and then browse the
location where you
want to create this project.
Let's create this
under the folder
which we had created earlier,
and then click on Create.
Oh, wait a minute.
Do we see an error here?
Well, that is expected.
And that's because I don't
have the right permissions yet
to be able to
create this project.
You need the resource manager
project's create permission
to be able to do so.
And this permission is included
in the project create role.
So let's quickly head on
to IAM and provision that.
We'll see IAM in a
little more detail
in just a couple of minutes.
When you come here,
you can already
see the permissions available
for a couple of users.
Let's just try and add a
new role and provision it
to myself.
Luckily, I have the permission
to give myself the permission
to be able to do so.
If not, someone else would
have to do it for me.
Anyway, I'm selecting project
creator here and saving it.
Now you can see that I have
the permission that I need,
so let's just go back
and create the project.
There are a bunch of ways where
you can go and land in the same
creating the new project page.
So maybe going here and clicking
on your project, or going back
and doing what we did before
through the Manage Resources
page.
I'm just going to go ahead
and give it this name,
browse the location,
and now click on Create.
This alarm bell
here will give us
a notification when the project
is ready and notifications
throughout.
There shouldn't be any error
now, so let's just wait.
Now let me quickly refresh the
page and expand the folder.
And here you go.
Your project has
now been created.
It's that easy.
Now that we have a
project to work with,
let's get a broad understanding
of the Google Cloud platform
console.
Always important to
keep in mind that you
need the required
permissions to access
any resource via the console
or the command line interface.
I'm selecting a project.
And your landing page
is your dashboard.
The dashboard gives
you an overview
of your project, some project
information, resources
you probably have provisioned,
monitoring details,
billing details, et cetera.
You can also customize what
you see on your dashboard
by clicking on the
Customize option.
Let's say I don't want the
project details and monitoring
details to show up.
So I'm just going to
switch the toggle buttons
and click on Done.
And as you can see, it's gone.
The next basic feature is
to the top left corner here.
It opens up the navigation menu.
It has all the
products and resources
that you can provision.
And for convenience,
it's segregated
based on different categories,
such as compute, serverless,
storage, databases, and more.
An additional feature
which comes in handy
is to pin the resources
that you use frequently.
You can further unpin it by
clicking on the same icon.
Another feature is if you're
in another product page,
all you have to do
is click on Home
to get back to your dashboard.
Click on this to
view the organization
name you're working in.
You have a list
of recent projects
you're working on here.
You can also star a couple
of important projects.
So let's see I star
the other project.
And you can see them
on the start tab.
To view all the projects
and folders, click on all.
You can further expand
or deflate them.
Now if I want to switch between
two projects, all I have to do
is select the new project
I want to work with,
and it's really that
simple to switch.
The three dots on top
here will take you
to these respective pages,
and the new project,
as you've already seen, is
to create a new project.
Right next to that we
have the search bar,
which is an easy way to find
anything on the Google Cloud
platform.
Moving back, this icon can be
used to activate your Cloud
Shell terminal.
This way, you can
type in your commands
instead of clicking your
way through resources.
You can also click
on Open editor
to get a full page terminal.
Coming back, clicking
on this question mark
here will act as the
help tool by guiding you
to a couple of resources.
The bell icon we
discussed earlier
is to view your notifications.
You can go through
the project settings
and different utilities
by clicking here.
Click on the extreme
right top corner
to manage the account with
which you're logging in.
So you can add an
account or sign out here.
For starters, this should help.
The more you work
on the platform,
the more you familiarize
yourself with it.
So get started
without any delay.
It's important to understand
three sections when
we talk about identity
and access management,
or IAMs on Google Cloud.
The who, does what, and on what.
The who is essentially the
identity part of the IAMs.
The who talks about whether it's
a single user, multiple users
separately, or multiple
users together.
Multiple users together is
what is referred to as a group,
and this is what
it is recommended.
The does what is the access
or set of access controls
the user has on a particular
set of resource or so.
For example, something
like an admin role
would allow you to
create, modify, delete,
add other roles, et cetera.
Whereas a viewer
role for a resource
would only allow
you to read from it
and not modify or delete it.
And finally, we
have the on what,
which talks about which resource
these obligations are put on.
So let's say a user has
only been granted access
to a particular
Cloud SQL database.
This does not allow the user
to access anything apart
from this particular
Cloud SQL database.
Here is an example to
understand it as a whole.
There are a group of users who
are granted the access of Cloud
SQL Viewer role, and this grants
them access to the Cloud SQL.
Here are some best
practices regarding IAMs.
Leverage and understand
the resource hierarchy.
Use projects to
group resources that
share the same trust boundary.
Check the policy
granted on each resource
and make sure you
understand the inheritance.
Use the principle of least
privilege, which means,
don't over-provision
any of the permissions
that a user does not require.
Ground rules to Google Groups
rather than individuals.
This way, when new
members are added,
they don't have to be permitted
all of those permissions again.
They just need to simply
be added to the group.
And finally, use predefined
role whenever possible,
as opposed to basic roles, which
gives us way too much access.
And customize roles
where you need to pick
and choose from a particular
set of permissions,
which can be hard to maintain.
Let's go over a very short
demonstration for IAM.
Let's head to the console.
Click on IAM in admin, which
has also been pinned here,
and make sure you're in IAM.
This is the IAM
dashboard, where you
can see a bunch of
different permissions
that have already been assigned.
I can add a new role
by either editing here,
by adding a new role, or I can
go ahead and click on Add here.
As I want to add it for the
same member, which is myself,
I'm just going to go ahead and
edit here, and add a new role.
Let's see, BigQuery viewer.
As you can see,
this has come up,
which means now I can access
and view the data from BigQuery.
Now I can go ahead
and delete this.
And as you can see, it's gone.
What next?
A couple of resources have been
added in the description box
below for you to check
out for you to get
more details on these concepts.
And that brings us to the
end of this video, where
we went to work creating a
new Google Cloud account,
did an overview of the
resource hierarchy.
We learned how to create
an organization, a folder,
and a project.
We did an entire run-through
of the Google Cloud console.
We understood in brief what
IAM is and wrapped it up
with a quick demo for IAM.
In the next episode,
you'll learn
about serverless
application deployment
and be introduced to App Engine,
Cloud Run, and Cloud Functions.
There'll be a section where
we deep dive into Cloud Run
and look at performance
and cost optimization.
We'll also run you through a
sample e-commerce application
architecture so you know what
a general architecture looks
like.
And wrap it up with a
customer success story
as to how it's actually
benefited a Google Cloud
customer.
Stay tuned for all the exciting
content that we have for you.
Don't forget to
like and subscribe
to our YouTube channel.
Click on the bell icon to
get notified every time
a video has been posted.
And we will see you very,
very soon in our next video.